hello and welcome to the shitty science
show were in this video will talk about
the fast crisper genome editing medicine
to be performed directly inside the
human body
so this landmark offense is the joint
collaboration between two companies
editors medicine and a legend and so
just the other week now they released
the reports where they announced dosing
of the first patient in a landmark phase
1/2 clinical trial of CRISPR medicine a
GN one five one five eight seven also
known as edits 101 the treatment of LCA
ten so we'll talk about that in a little
bit more detail in this video so firstly
will mention what is this CRISPR
technology and why is this such a
landmark study and then we'll look at
what is the disease that they're trying
to treat and then how they're using
CRISPR to treat it and before I forget
up on your screens now is the report
that was released on March the 4th this
is free for anyone to look at so I'll
put the link for that in the description
so CRISPR then as I explained before in
a previous video I feel like I'm
somewhat of a CRISPR expert whether or
not that's completely trade technique
but I studied it a lot during my
Master's project so let's briefly talk
about the CRISPR technology so when you
hear of the term CRISPR or filter and
that's referring to the CRISPR caste 9
system so this is a system that's been
exploited as a gene editing tool from a
bacterial defense mechanism and so the
way that this works is you have a
protein known as class 9 which is a DNA
and any place which means it can cut the
doll from the DNA strand and it's kind
of two specific locations in the genome
fear a guide RNA and so you can tailor
these guide RNAs for any specific
location in the genome to targets the
class 9 protein and so you can kind of
decide where the cast iron protein will
introduce this break into the DNA the
cell that needs to repair this break and
it can do this in an error-prone method
or you can introduce a donor template
with a specific modification that you
want to make in the genome to fix and
edit the genome effectively so the
choice of cast lines up here you can see
there's two ending it plays domains
which cut either strand of the DNA and
so CRISPR is a really flexible tool to
be able to make targeted
into the genome so how could it be used
for treating diseases well let's talk
about the example here that edit as
medicine and a legend have done so there
are two main types of crystal medicines
in fever CRISPR medicines that edit
genes inside the body which is in this
case here and ex-vivo engineered cell
medicines where CRISPR gene editing
occurs outside the body to create edited
cell medicines there are then
administered to patient
so just to elaborate this point a bit
further the in vivo Chris of medicine is
where you take the CRISPR material
Angie directly put that into the cells
in the human body whereas the engineered
medicines are when you can take some of
the patient sample and their DNA modify
it test it and then reintroduce it to
the patient and so as I mentioned this
by rekhs and fever approach is what
makes this such a landmark study um in
this case we're talking about today so
this in theory CRISPR medicine has been
designed to treat LCA 10 so what
actually is LCA 10 so it stands for
labor congenital amaurosis 10 and so LCA
is a group of inherited retinal
degenerative disorders caused by
mutations in different genes and
previously as a thinner untreatable
disease and is a common cause of
inherited childhood blindness and so the
case of LCA 10 it's caused by mutations
in the centrosome or protein
290 gene otherwise refer to accept 290
and so the key thing is it's caused by
mutations and this causes degeneration
in ocular photoreceptor cells which is
critical for normal vision but the fact
that it's a mutation is suggestive that
if we can fix this mutation we can refer
the generative effects in the cells so
the question is how can we use CRISPR to
fix this mutation and so this is the
idea behind edits 101 which is the aim
behind this clinical trial and say what
they want to do is as I said to remove
the set to 19 mutation and to be able to
restore normal protein expression all
the sexy 90 to restore photoreceptor
function and
so if you go into the edit house
medicine websites you'll find an
overview of the current strategy of how
they're trying to fix this mutation so
this mutation occurs between X 126 and
excellent 27 in the step 290 gene and so
this isn't a non-coding region of the
gene
but that isn't really too important to
understand what they're doing what they
want to do is get rid of this mutation
and so they want to delete this fragment
of DNA that contains the mutation so
what their approach is is to have to
guide RNAs that go into two regions
flanking the mutation you get a double
strand break by the caste line and then
you get removal and deletion of this
intermediate fragment and hopefully that
would have restored the protein
expression and hence the receptor
function and vision and so this is an
experimental medicine and as I said
before it's a indirect and feeble
approach and so they deliver it feeis
subretinal injection so how do they do
this well it's a final process and I
know far is probably the last thing you
would talk about at the moment but this
isn't the Feres that everyone stood him
up this is Anna been a associated virus
which is very safe in comparison just
because a denno associated viruses are
not currently known to cause disease and
so this is just a mechanism where they
put the cast iron genome sequence and
the guide RNAs they package it into this
virus and then the virus will infect the
cells around the photoreceptor cells so
you can introduce the cast line material
that can then fix the step 290 gene and
so this is just the way that they do
this approach and so naturally there are
always going to be concerns with using
any kind of viral mediated gene transfer
so to make this a little bit more safe
they only have cast line expression in
photoreceptor cells because they have
the expression of cat line regulated by
a photoreceptor specific GRK one
parameter which is only expressed in
photoreceptor cells and so this
minimizes the expression of class 9 to
other cells in the body so
it should only be in those cell types
where you have cast an expression where
you get the editing so where are they
out then with the treatment of this
disease so as I mentioned they've just
started dating the first patients in
this phase 1/2 clinical trial and so
it's also known as the brilliant stroll
and so the aim of this was at such an
early stage of clinical trial is to
assess the safety the tolerability
and the efficacy of this treatment like
cool it even work let alone is that safe
for the patients to take and so
currently they have 18 patients and
additional patient enrollment is still
ongoing and each of these patients if
they sign up for this trial are
receiving a single administration of
this virally packaged crispa treatment
for yourself retinol injection so and
this is also only in one eye so this is
very exciting news and I'm pretty
certain will only hear more news like
this in the upcoming months and years to
come
so as always hopefully you've learned
something and thank you for listening